Je vais vous parler aujourd'hui de
la transformation, je l'espère, de la peur en espoir.
Quand nous allons chez le médecin aujourd'hui,
quand nous pénétrons dans le cabinet du docteur,
il y a des mots que nous ne voulons pas entendre.
Il y a des mots dont nous avons vraiment peur.
Diabète, cancer, Parkinson, Alzheimer,
défaillance cardiaque, défaillance pulmonaire.
Nous savons que ce sont des maladies débilitantes,
contre lesquelles il y a relativement peu de choses à faire.
Et ce que je veux vous montrer aujourd'hui c'est
une façon différente d'aborder le traitement des maladies débilitantes,
pourquoi c'est important.
Pourquoi sans ça, notre sécurité sociale risque de s'effondrer,
si vous pensez que ce n'est pas déjà le cas.
Et où nous en sommes aujourd'hui cliniquement, où nous pourrions être demain
et quels sont certains des obstacles.
Et je vous promets, nous ferons tout cela en 18 minutes.
Je voudrais commencer avec cette diapositive,
parce qu'en quelque sorte, cette diapositve raconte l'histoire telle que le magazine Science la voit.
C'est un numéro de 2002
où ils ont publié différents articles sur l'humain bionique.
En fait c'était un numéro sur la médecine régénérative.
La médecine régénérative est un concept extraordinairement simple
que tout le monde peut comprendre.
Cela consiste simplement à accélérer le rythme auquel le corps se soigne lui-même
jusqu'à un délai significatif sur le plan clinique.
Nous savons donc comment faire ça de plusieurs manières comme ici.
Nous savons que si nous avons une hanche endommagée, elle peut être remplacée par une hanche artificielle.
Et c'est l'idée que le magazine Science a utilisé en couverture.
Ceci est l'antithèse absolue de la médecine régénérative.
Ce n'est pas de la médecine régénérative.
La médecine régénérative est ce que le magazine Business Week a publié
quand ils ont fait un papier sur la médecine régénérative il y a quelque temps.
L'idée c'est qu'au lieu de chercher comment améliorer les symptômes
avec des appareils et des médicaments et autres --
j'y reviendrai dans un moment --
au lieu de faire ça, nous régénérerons des fonctions perdues du corps
en régénérant la fonction des organes et des tissus endommagés.
Ainsi à la fin du traitement,
vous êtes le même qu'au début du traitement.
Très peu de bonnes idées -- si vous êtes d'accord que c'est une bonne idée --
très peu de bonnes idées sont vraiment nouvelles.
Et c'est la même chose ici.
Si nous regardons en arrière,
Charles Lindberg -- qui était plus connu comme pilote d'avion --
fut en fait une des premières personnes,
avec Alexis Carrel de l'Université Rockefeller, lauréat du prix Nobel,
à commencer à se demander si nous pourrions cultiver des organes.
Et ils ont publié ce livre en 1937,
où ils commençaient à se demander
ce que nous pourrions faire au niveau des bio-réacteurs pour faire pousser des organes.
Nous avons beaucoup avancé depuis.
Je vais partager avec vous quelques uns des travaux passionnants du moment.
Mais avant, ce que je voudrais faire
c'est vous faire part de mon inquiétude au sujet de la sécurité sociale
et sa nécessité.
Hier il y a eu plusieurs présentations sur
la façon d'améliorer la qualité de vie et de réduire la pauvreté.
Et essentiellement augmenter la durée de vie dans le monde.
L'un des défis est que plus nous sommes riches, plus nous vivons longtemps.
Et plus nous vivons longtemps, plus cela coûte cher
de guérir nos maladies quand nous vieillissons.
C'est simplement la richesse d'un pays
versus le pourcentage de le population qui a plus de 65 ans.
Et vous pouvez effectivement voir que plus un pays est riche,
plus sa population est agée.
Pourquoi est-ce important ?
Et pourquoi est-ce un défi majeur aujourd'hui?
Si l'âge moyen de la population est de 30 ans,
alors le type de maladies qui vous devez traiter en moyenne
c'est un cheville cassée de temps en temps,
peut être un peu d'asthme.
Si l'âge moyen de votre pays est de 45 à 55 ans,
la personne moyenne est sujette au diabète,
diabète précoce, défaillance cardiaque, maladie coronarienne.
Choses qui sont par nature plus difficiles à traiter,
et beaucoup plus chères à traiter.
Regardez ici la démographie des Etats-Unis.
Ceci vient du livre "Les Etats Désunis d'Amérique".
En 1930, il y avait 41 travailleurs par retraité.
41 personnes sans maladies graves,
payants pour un retraité sujet à des maladies débilitantes.
En 2010, 2 travailleurs par retraité aux Etats-Unis.
Et ceci est similaire dans chaque pays riche et industrialisé dans le monde.
Et maintenant comment pouvez-vous vous permettre financièrement de traiter des patients,
quand la réalité du vieillissement ressemble à ça ?
Ceci est l'âge versus le coût des soins de santé.
Et vous pouvez voir qu'aux environs de 45 ans, de 40 à 45 ans,
il y a un pic soudain dans le coût des soins de santé.
En fait c'est assez intéressant -- si vous faîtes les bonnes études,
vous pouvez mesurer vos propres dépenses en soins de santé,
en fonction de votre durée de vie.
Et environ 7 ans avant votre mort, il y a un pic.
Et en fait vous pouvez --
(Rires)
-- je ne vais pas aborder ça.
Il y a vraiment peu de choses que vous pouvez faire
qui changeraient le moyen de traiter ce genre de maladies
et connaître ce que j'appellerais le vieillessement en bonne santé.
Je suggèrerais 4 moyens.
Aucun de ces moyens n'implique de sécurité sociale ou un système juridique.
Ce que ces moyens font c'est changer le payeur.
Ils ne changent pas le coût des traitements.
Une chose que vous pouvez faire c'est ne pas traiter. Vous pouvez rationner les soins de santé.
Nous n'allons plus parler de ça. C'est trop déprimant.
Vous pouvez prévenir.
Evidemment de grosses sommes d'argent devraient être investies dans la prévention.
Mais peut-être plus intéressante, au moins pour moi, et plus importante,
est l'idée de diagnostiquer la maladie beaucoup plus tôt au cours de sa progression,
et traiter alors la maladie pour guérir la maladie,
au lieu de traiter les symptômes.
Prenons l'exemple du diabète.
Aujourd'hui, avec le diabète, que faisons-nous?
Nous diagnostiquons la maladie une fois seulement qu'elle devient symptomatique,
et nous traitons le symptôme pour 10, 20, 30, 40 ans.
Et nous faisons les choses bien. L'insuline est une très bonne thérapie.
Mais ça s'arrête de marcher à un moment donné,
et le diabète engendre des maladies débilitantes prévisibles.
Pour est-ce que nous n'injecterions pas quelque chose dans le pancréas
pour régénérer le pancréas suffisamment tôt au cours de la maladie,
peut-être même avant qu'elle devienne symptomatique ?
Et ça peut être un peu cher à ce moment là,
mais si ça fonctionne, nous serions vraiment capable de faire quelque chose de différent.
Cette vidéo, je pense, exprime très clairement le concept dont je suis en train de parler.
Ceci est un triton faisant repousser son membre.
Si un triton peut faire ce genre de choses, pourquoi pas nous ?
Je vais vous montrer certaines caractéristiques encore plus importantes
de la régénération des membres dans un moment.
Mais ce dont il est question quand nous parlons de médecine régénérative
c'est de faire de même avec toutes les parties du corps,
pour les tissus et les organes eux-mêmes.
La réalité d'aujourd'hui est que si vous tombez malade,
nous traiterons vos symptômes,
et vous devrez vous adapter à un nouveau mode de vie.
Je vous parie que demain --
et nous pourrions débattre de quand demain sera,
mais c'est dans un proche avenir --
nous parlerons de rééducation régénérative.
Ce que vous voyez là est une prothèse de membre,
similaire à celle qu'un soldat
qui revient d'Irak...
370 soldats sont revenus d'Irak en ayant perdu un membre.
Imaginez si au lieu d'affronter cela, ils
affrontaient plutôt la régénération de ce membre.
C'est une idée folle.
Je vais vous montrer où nous sommes actuellement dans le développement de ce concept.
Mais, à nouveau, c'est applicable à tous les systèmes d'organes.
Comment pouvons-nous faire ça?
Pour y parvenir, nous devons développer une conversation avec le corps.
Il nous faut apprendre le langage du corps.
Et mettre en marche des processus que nous maîtrisions quand nous étions un fœtus.
Un fœtus de mammifère, s'il perd un membre durant le premier trimestre de la grossesse,
va faire repousser ce membre.
Donc notre ADN a la capacité de générer des mécanismes de guérison des blessures.
C'est un processus naturel,
mais nous le perdons en vieillissant.
Chez les enfants, avant l'âge d'environ 6 mois,
s'ils perdent le bout de leurs doigts dans un accident,
ils les font repousser.
Quand ils ont 5 ans, ils ne sont plus capables de le faire.
Donc pour engager une conversation avec le corps,
nous avons besoin de parler le langage du corps.
Et il y a certains outils dans notre boîte à outils qui nous permettent de faire ça aujourd'hui.
Je vais vous donner un exemple de 3 de ces outils
grâce auxquels nous pouvons converser avec le corps.
Le premier est la thérapie cellulaire.
Clairement, nous nous guérissons par un processus naturel,
utilisant des cellules pour faire la plupart du travail.
Par conséquent, si nous pouvons trouver les bonnes cellules
et les implanter dans le corps, elles pourraient engendrer la guérison.
Deuxièmement, nous pouvons utiliser des matériaux.
Hier nous avons entendu parlé de l'importance des nouveaux matériaux.
Si nous pouvons inventer des matériaux, les concevoir,
ou extraire des matériaux d'un environnement naturel,
alors nous pourrions être capable de provoquer l'auto-guérison du corps par l'utilisation de ces matériaux.
Et finalement, nous pourrions être capables d'utiliser des appareils intelligents
qui délesteraient le corps de son travail et lui permettraient de guérir.
Je vais vous montrer un exemple de chacun d'eux,
et je vais commencer avec les matériaux.
Steve Badylak -- qui est à l'université de Pittsburgh --
il y a environ une décennie, a eu une idée remarquable.
Et cette idée était que le petit intestin de porc,
si vous jetiez toutes les cellules,
et si vous le faisiez de manière à ce qu'il reste biologiquement actif,
pourrait contenir tous les facteurs et signaux nécessaires
pour faire signe au corps de s'auto-guérir.
Et il a posé une question très importante.
Il a posé la question suivante,
si je prends ce matériau, qui est un matériau naturel
qui provoque d'habitude la guérison du petit intestin,
et que je le place sur une autre partie du corps d'une personne,
est-ce que ça donnerait un résultat spécifique au tissu,
ou est-ce que ça fabriquerait un petit intestin si j'essayais de faire une nouvelle oreille ?
Je ne vous raconterais pas cette histoire si elle n'était pas probante.
L'image que je vais vous montrer --
(Rires)
-- est une image fascinante.
Cependant, pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont un tant soit peu impressionnables --
même si vous n'aimez pas l'admettre devant vos amis --
les lumières sont baissées. C'est un bon moment pour regarder vos pieds,
vérifier votre BlackBerry, faire autre chose que regarder l'écran.
(Rires)
Ce que je vais vous montrer est un ulcère diabétique.
Et bien que -- c'est bien de rire avant de regarder ça.
Ceci est la réalité du diabète.
Je pense que très souvent, quand nous entendons parler de diabétiques, d'ulcères diabétiques,
nous ne faisons pas le rapport entre l'ulcère et le traitement éventuel,
qui est l'amputation, si vous ne pouvez pas le guérir.
Je vais faire apparaître la diapositive maintenant. Ce ne sera pas trop long.
Ceci est un ulcère diabétique. C'est tragique.
Le traitement pour ça, c'est l'amputation.
Voici une dame plus âgée. Elle a un cancer du foie ainsi que du diabète,
et a décidé de mourir avec ce qui reste de son corps.
Et cette dame a décidé, après un an de tentative de traitement de cet ulcère,
d'essayer cette nouvelle thérapie que Steve a inventé.
Voilà à quoi ressemble la blessure après 11 semaines.
Ce matériau ne contenait que des signaux naturels.
Et ce matériau a provoqué un changement dans la réponse du corps en déclenchant une réponse de guérison,
qu'il n'avait pas avant.
Il va y avoir encore quelques images difficiles pour ceux d'entre vous qui --
Je vous ferais savoir quand vous pouvez regarder de nouveau.
Ceci est un cheval. Ce cheval ne souffre pas.
Si le cheval avait mal, je ne vous montrerais pas cette diapositive.
Le cheval a juste une autre narine qui s'est développée
à cause d'un accident d'équitation.
Seulement quelques semaines après le traitement --
dans ce cas précis en appliquant ce matériau sous forme de gel,
entourant de bandages cette partie, et répétant ensuite le traitement plusieurs fois --
le cheval guéri.
Et si vous faisiez une échographie de cette surface, elle est impeccable.
Voici un dauphin dont la nageoire a été ré-attachée.
Il y a maintenant 400 000 patients dans le monde
qui ont utilisé ce matériau pour guérir leurs blessures.
Pourriez-vous régénérer un membre?
DARPA vient de donner à Steve 15 millions de dollars pour mener un projet incluant 8 institutions
pour commencer à se poser cette question.
Je vous montrerais l'image à 15 millions de dollars.
Voici un homme de 78 ans qui avait perdu le bout de son doigt.
Souvenez-vous des enfants qui perdent le bout de leurs doigts dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure.
Après traitement voilà à quoi ça ressemble.
Ceci a lieu aujourd'hui.
Ceci est significatif cliniquement aujourd'hui.
Il y a des matériaux qui font ça. Voici les patchs cardiaques.
Mais peut-on aller un peu plus loin ?
Disons, au lieu d'utiliser un matériau,
est-ce que je peux prendre quelques cellules avec le matériau,
retirer une partie de tissu endommagé,
et mettre un matériau bio-dégradable dessus ?
Vous pouvez voir ici un peu de muscle cardiaque battre dans un récipient.
Ceci a été fait par Teruo Okano à l'Hôpital pour Femmes de Tokyo.
Il peut réellement faire pousser des tissus vivant dans un récipient.
Il refroidit le récipient, ce qui change ses propriétés
et il le décolle du récipient.
C'est le truc le plus sympa.
Maintenant je vais vous montrer une régénération à partir des cellules.
Et ce que je vais vous montrer ici
ce sont des cellules souches en train d'être retirées de la hanche d'un patient.
Encore une fois, si vous êtes sensibles, ne regardez pas.
Mais celui-là est plutôt sympa.
Ceci est un pontage, comme celui qu'Al-Gore a subi,
avec une différence.
Dans ce cas précis, à la fin du pontage,
vous allez voir les cellules souches du patient
qui ont été retirées au début de la procédure
être directement injectées dans le cœur du patient.
Et je me suis déplacé ici parce qu'à un moment
je vais vous montrer à quel point la technologie est en avance.
Les cellules souches vont ici, à l'intérieur même du cœur en train de battre du patient.
Et si vous regardez vraiment attentivement,
ça va se passer à peu près ici
vous verrez un rinçage à circulation inversée.
Vous voyez les cellules qui ressortent.
Nous avons besoin de différents types de nouvelles technologies, de nouveaux appareils,
pour que les cellules soient au bon endroit au bon moment.
Juste un petit peu de données, un tout petit peu de données.
C'était un essai aléatoire.
A ce moment-là, c'était un N sur 20. Maintenant c'est un N sur environ 100.
En fait, si vous prenez des patients extrêmement malades
et vous leur faîtes un pontage, ils se sentiront un peu mieux.
Si vous leur donnez des cellules souches en plus du pontage
ces patients-là deviendront asymptomatiques.
C'était il y a deux ans.
Le mieux serait de pouvoir diagnostiquer la maladie plus tôt,
et prévenir le début de la maladie avant qu'elle n'empire.
Ceci est la même procédure, mais réalisée de manière minimalement invasive,
avec seulement 3 trous dans le corps d'où ils prennent le cœur
et injecte des cellules souches par une chirurgie laparoscopique.
Voici les cellules.
Nous n'avons pas le temps d'aller dans les détails,
mais en gros, ça fonctionne aussi.
Vous pouvez prendre des patients qui sont moins malades,
et les ramener à un état presque asymptomatique
avec ce genre de thérapie.
Voici un autre exemple de thérapie à base de cellules souches qui n'est pas encore vraiment clinique,
mais le sera très bientôt je pense.
Ceci est le travail de Kacey Marra de Pittsburgh,
avec de nombreux collègues dans le monde.
Ils ont décidé que le liquide de la liposuccion,
-- aux Etats Unis, nous avons beaucoup de liquide provenant des liposuccions.
(Rires)
C'est une grande source de cellules souches.
les cellules souches sont concentrées dans ce liquide de liposuccion.
Alors vous pourriez y aller, et prendre votre plastie abdominale.
Le liquide de liposuccion en sort,
et dans ce cas, les cellules souches sont isolées et transformées en neurones.
Tout a été fait au labo.
Et je pense qu'assez tôt, vous verrez des patients se faire traiter
avec leurs propres cellules souches dérivées de gras, ou de tissu adipeux.
J'ai parlé précédemment de l'utilisation d'appareils
pour changer radicalement la manière dont nous traitons la maladie.
Voici un dernier exemple avant de finir.
Ceci est également tragique.
Nous avons un partenariat très fort et indéfectible
avec nos collègues de l'Institut de Recherche Chirurgicale de l'Armée Américaine,
qui doivent traiter les maintenant 11 000 jeunes soldats qui sont revenus d'Irak.
La plupart de ces patients sont gravement brulés.
Et s'il y a quelque chose que nos avons appris au sujet des brûlures,
c'est que nous ne savons pas comment les traiter.
Tout ce qui est fait pour soigner les brûlures --
en fait nous avons une drôle d'approche.
Nous fabriquons quelque chose par ici,
et ensuite nous le transplantons à l'endroit de la blessure,
et nous essayons de faire en sorte que les deux prennent.
Dans ce cas précis, un nouveau bio-réacteur portable a été créé --
il devrait être testé cliniquement plus tard cette année à l'ISR --
par Joerg Gerlach à Pittsburgh.
Et ce bio-réacteur sera appliqué sur la blessure.
Le pistolet que vous voyez ici vaporise les cellules.
Ça va vaporiser les cellules sur cette surface.
Le réacteur va servir à fertiliser l'environnement,
à distribuer d'autres choses en même temps,
on va donc ensemencer cette pelouse,
au lieu d'essayer l'autre approche.
C'est une façon complètement différente de procéder.
Mes 18 minutes touchent à leur fin.
Alors laissez-moi finir avec de bonnes nouvelles,
et peut-être un peu de mauvaises nouvelles.
La bonne nouvelle est que ceci est en application aujourd'hui.
C'est un travail très puissant.
Les images le montrent clairement.
C'est incroyablement difficile parce que c'est hautement interdisciplinaire.
Presque tous les champs de la science, de l'ingénierie et des pratiques cliniques
sont impliqués dans cette tentative.
Nombre de gouvernements et de régions
ont reconnu que ceci est un nouveau moyen de soigner les maladies.
Le gouvernement japonais était peut-être le premier,
quand ils ont décidé d'investir d'abord 3 milliards,
puis 2 autres milliards dans ce domaine.
Ce n'est pas une coïncidence.
Le Japon est le plus vieux pays en termes d'âge moyen.
Ils ont besoin que ça fonctionne sinon leur système de santé meurt.
Alors ils font beaucoup d'investissements stratégiques spécifiquement dans ce domaine.
L'Union Européenne, même chose.
La Chine, même chose
La Chine vient de lancer un centre national d'ingénierie tissulaire.
Le budget de la première année était de 250 millions de dollars.
Aux Etats-Unis, nous avons une approche quelque peu différente. Nous --
(Rires)
-- oh, pour qu'Al Gore devienne président dans le monde réel.
Nous avons eu une approche différente.
Et l'approche a globalement été de subventionner les choses au fur et à mesure.
Mais il n'y eu aucun investissement stratégique
pour apporter tous les éléments nécessaires et les mettre au point avec attention.
Et je vais finir avec une citation, peut-être un petit coup bas
au directeur du NIH (Institut National de la Santé), qui est un homme très charmant.
Jay Vacanti de Harvard et moi-même
lui ont rendu visite ainsi qu'à de nombreux directeurs de son institut
il y a seulement quelques mois,
pour essayer et le convaincre qu'il était temps de prendre juste une petite partie
des 27,5 milliards de dollars qu'il touchera l'année prochaine
et de l'investir de manière stratégique, pour faire en sorte que nous puissions accélérer le rythme
auquel les patients reçoivent ces traitements.
Et à la fin de cette réunion houleuse,
ce que le directeur du NIH a dit est,
"Votre vision est plus grande que notre appétit."
J'aimerai finir en disant que personne ne va changer notre vision,
mais qu'ensemble nous pouvons changer son appétit.
Merci.